i hear a famous priest is arriving today  oh i've heard of him too he has quite a  reputation  they say he can heal any illness  they say he travels he's coming here to  search for something  i wonder what he's like he just passed  by where where is he  is that really him he looks far too  young does he really have healing powers  he looks rather frail daddy who's that  a very famous  priest welcome to pride home holy one  thank you so much for this warm welcome  father  varu and the rest of the village eagerly  await your arrival at the cathedral oh  in that case i best not keep father  verroot waiting  now  [Music]  thank you for saving me  are you headed to pride home  [Music]